welcome back to our channel my name is
samuel and i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about
money marriage and life and i hope you
are having a fantastic week
if you are not subscribed please
subscribe to the channel smash the like
button
why should they subscribe to the channel
because we give lots and lots of good
content here
yeah every single day there's a video
and every single week you've got the
samuel and amanda show so if you've got
questions for us specifically around
money marriage live kids holidays
the universe anything at all comment it
below
and then when we do our next week's
video we will use your questions we
never really get
any questions no i think people forget
so this is the opportunity now to
comment down below if you have any
questions for us
and we'll do our best to answer your
questions for next week's video
however right now what have you been up
to this week this week
has been a week of firsts for me um so
i've been driving for 10 years
i've never never had any penalty points
for my speeding or anything like that
never had any bumps and then this week i
had a little accident
and i was just i just don't even
understand
still how it happened you know when you
keep replaying something over and over
in your mind
i keep doing that and i just can't
figure out it was a bad accident
i have a conspiracy about this incident
and i've got circumstantial evidence to
prove this is right
off the back of our previous podcast
right go on
for the last three weeks amanda has been
complaining
about her car oh yeah true she's you've
had a cover car
it was an ugly car she used to have a
discovery sport she's ordered the brand
new electric mercedes
and in the meantime she had this ugly
big gray i don't know
it was a bmw but it's just not
attractive looking on there she hated it
she's always moaning about it oh when's
my electric car coming
um and i think that she crashed it on
purpose
oh my god no no no i think that
subconsciously
you wanted that car going i think
subconsciously i probably didn't
sabotage it myself but subconsciously
this was not perfect this wasn't a knock
this wasn't i oh i bumped it or
this is a like i've smashed it up yeah
um they actually taken away and
everything i was in the car at the time
as well i was fearing for my life
it wasn't that bad what actually
happened thankfully no one was hurt as
well tell us what happened how did the
crash happen
oh my god it was someone who thought
that they were doing me a good deed
telling me to go giving me way i
my fault didn't double check my side to
make sure i was clear to go
and then i went and then i hit the car
that was coming from my right so
yeah it was it was really he's my bad
but you thought afterwards you were like
he
waved me on that i was like why was he
telling me why would you ever
give someone way like if there's a guy
so
so you're coming out to her to a
junction yeah
and um look to your eyes it's clear look
at the left and someone's waiting and
then the goddess went and goes yeah yeah
he's like making me go so then i think
we're not making you guys okay not me
telling you that you can go but
encouraging you with his gestures
he was encouraging me mandy pulls out
but literally
um it smacks a little
lorry thing yeah and both cars really in
a bad way
however the crazy thing is the car that
you basically wrote off
the they they kind of picked it up moved
it away so don't worry we'll get you a
new car tomorrow and she was like let's
hope the new car is even better
but it was in fact an even worse yeah
from a car
so i'm really worried for my sins and
i'm really worried now that you're gonna
write off that new car
oh my goodness i don't think i will i
don't think i will but oh my goodness so
yeah that's my
that's been my week this week that's
been annoying enjoying the weather again
so back to my usual
you know enjoying the sunshine outside
with the kids yeah
we're for a picnic yesterday so that was
fun and yeah
lots of life admin as well in between so
great
and we've got loads of really
interesting development deals going on
we've i've been
traveling all around i've been running
events i've been running discovery days
i've been making
youtube videos uh i've been planning
your
birthday it's my birthday next week
how how how old are you going to be in
fact how old do you reckon she'll be
should we even do that
yeah i guess yes they'll know they'll be
able to
i don't know find out very easily
beautiful face is deceiving
amanda is gonna be 29. i'm gonna be 29.
so you're now 28.
yep um so you're gonna be 29.
was just laughing about the time when i
tricked you oh my god i know we've
talked about this haven't we
we haven't slowly tricked amanda to
thinking she was two years younger than
cheshire was but anyway that's a little
story
so for your birthday what are we doing
we're going
to sand banks and that's like our
favorite area in the uk it's really nice
it's a beach our favorite hotel is there
as well
however sarah's been trying to book it
but it's like fully booked until next
year
so we can't even stay there i got so
desperate trying to find a hotel that i
like to reach out on
social media and post instagram saying
are there any hotels
in dorset like i can't book anything
not just on samban speech but within
half an hour radius there's just
nothing i've been on airbnb
everywhere's full and um i ended up
having
a lady on social media who it follows me
i
actually think we've ever met but saying
that she's got an apartment there
it's not an airbnb it's not listed
anywhere it's just her private apartment
and she happens to not be staying there
at the moment
and she said that we can go and stay
there which is amazing but
again it just goes to show the absolute
power
right now of service to combat right so
true
like if you're not in on that yet just
jump on it for now because staycations i
think at the moment
are the way to go because travel's so
hard it's so hard even booking airbnb
yeah oh my gosh airbnb i mean i just
don't understand
it's so difficult every time we try it's
like
give us your passport do this do that do
this i guess it's good because you know
you don't want any
any person just coming in and staying
and then possibly trash in your place
but yeah
you have to jump through hoops it is
really hard it is really hard airbnb
to sort themself out and make it more
simple and smoother yes so we'll tell
you next week about what happened on
your birthday
yeah and how that goes and how you get
on in a stranger's
apartment 15 minutes from sandbanks
beach but we'll
uh i'm sure we'll have fun so big
week this week because we've had the
euros yes
and if you if you if you know my wife
amanda you'll know that she's a bigger
fan of football than
oh my goodness yeah yeah from math i get
so invested
so just generally speaking i don't watch
football but
when i do i watch it when it's the
england games and then i'm
really like in it i'm like totally
invested my brother russell's really
into football but
the england will start playing you know
the first one or two games and mandy
won't even watch it she'll just like ah
whatever whatever yeah and then and then
she'll be like oh so they're actually
looking like they might protect you yeah
you could win they've got what three or
four oh god and then she'll watch your
game
come on
when we win then she's just like a
lunatic crazy so we went to watch the uh
the england game in london
not out when not um wembley stadium but
we went we
it was even hard enough just finding a
restaurant or a pub that would
have space for you to watch it was major
the finals uh we didn't win
we came close mandy was screaming and
shouting and cheering like crazy
no i know i really was but you know what
i was so proud because i think
for england to get that far it was just
amazing in itself but i was really good
that they didn't win but yeah lost on
penalties yeah
could have gone either way yeah um you
know but but what about
that clip of you that i said on social
media we blew up because you were
literally
that was from the last tournament i
think but oh my gosh i can't remember
which game that was but i went crazy
when they won
yeah i just get so excited and i'm like
jack come on
you gotta love the feeling what are the
people now saying though that oh there
needs to be a really i don't know if
you've seen the people saying there
needs to be a rematch
between italy and england really yeah
because apparently there's like 150 000
people
of of of signed the um petition and
they're saying that italy were
played he pulled us around and stuff but
it's like okay i think they're probably
referring to when
saku i i think yeah saku he got dragged
in
he pulled his collar and then he like
fell back that's probably that they were
dirty but
my attitude is sometimes you just need
to just number one
if it was really that bad they would
have just
the reference yeah the referee at the
time i picked up on it i don't think
it's that deep i think i think the game
was it was
so well yeah i'm just proud that we got
into the absolute finals that's just
incredible yeah um
a lot of backlash afterwards as well
with racism happening and things like
that what's yours
you know what's crazy the the three
players that missed the penalties
yeah they were black and mixed race at
the time i didn't even notice this i'm
just watching the game
just just you know oh the play i'm just
like oh oh got it oh he saved the ball
that's it and then the following day
even that evening actually
everyone's then saying oh um well i saw
people retweeting stuff on twitter
saying oh everyone's racist comments
about the three players that missed the
goals and they were black and i was just
like
as if that's even a thing like who even
notices that they're one team
like who cares and it's just it's just
stupid it's just i think
all the racism is like ridiculous and
just stupid
but i do think there's the guy um who
works at saviles
who was saying something really bad i
saw that they tracked him down
racist racist comments yeah saviles have
now fired him i mean how embarrassing
his way imagine that imagine just having
to be like oh yeah
and he denied it he was actually uh it
wasn't me yeah someone hacked my account
it's like what would you why would you
hack someone's account who's got seven
followers and nobody
yeah who works at samples
what do you think about the whole
because there's a lot of talk about at
the moment in the news they're talking
about
when people go on social media having to
take their
passport so that they know who they are
because there's arguments for and
against the arguments four are
you've got to have accountability you
can't just post anonymously on social
media
and then not be consequences you need to
be you know if you
you can't just go up to someone's face
and start saying threatening harassing
a racist or whatever it might be things
to someone's face and expect to know
consequences
social media should be no different so
you should have to put your passport in
but then other people say
it's like a slippery slope because it's
like government control and
knowing exactly who everyone is all the
time and what they're saying and yeah
i mean what do you think i can see both
sides however i would definitely go for
more the
get a passport verify yourself um to be
on social media because like you have to
verify yourself to be on airbnb
yeah yeah just like that because i mean
why should you be able to just make up
an anonymous account and have multiple
accounts
we've heard that we've all got that
against me people setting up you know
yeah
50 accounts and then they've got all
these different accounts if it names
trolling
yeah yeah i think it's unacceptable it
is unacceptable yeah it is exciting and
it looks like there's a load of people
but actually they're all fake accounts
yeah for the same person and then
it's been proved and then the police
just go oh that's bad
sometimes i take it seriously we
prosecute people yeah we've had people
we've had people arrested haven't we
yeah and
prosecuted for for things online against
me
i'm like i'm not i'm personally just not
having it yeah um
and um and i think yeah i think that
they should i agree i think that they
should i think it would deter people a
bit because if
right now people can just say whatever
they want because there is no
consequences but
well there are consequences but well
yeah but it's just not
widely known yeah it's not widely known
is it so
but i just think that if you knew your
passport was attached to your account
and you know people could id you
straight away i think you'd think twice
before you actually said something
because people are a different person
online than they are no one would come
up to you
and say you and start shouting racial
stuff your face but then online
somehow then somehow yeah people have
the courage yeah the audacity yeah the
audacity i should say
yeah to think that to think that it's
okay um
so yeah it's it's wrong and i think that
i think it's good that i tell you what
that i was actually annoyed
with boris johnson's oh my gosh
absolutely i loved what you tweeted no i
was like boris johnson came out but
boris johnson said you people should be
ashamed of yourselves
and i hope that you crawl back under the
rock that you came from that was his
he's got
now that is so stupid yeah of course
like as if he's going to expect us to be
like oh poor boris voice
because boris is not can
number one you should be ashamed of
yourself no they shouldn't be ashamed of
themselves
they should be held to account right
that's the first thing
it should you should be saying not you
should be ashamed they're not gonna be
like oh sorry boris i should be ashamed
i know
all right and then the second thing is
you should crawl back into the rock that
you came from
no they shouldn't they should be dragged
into i know i know we need to see them
yeah not not crawl under the rock that
they came from that's exactly
where they want to be hiding under a
rock typing on their keyboards
you know no they should be called to
account in the courtroom
and face charges for what they did
that's what needs to happen
and so i think boris's stance on it was
very weak love to know what you guys
think though
let us know in the comments do you think
that um people should be held to account
for what they say online
i think that online it's like there's
two different worlds it's online and
there's real life
but no you have to i know it's all real
life
so yeah the same energy you bring online
you need to bring it in but what people
don't realize
is that there are consequences but it's
just not known that there are
like there was somebody that called a uh
a solicitors
firm they've left a trust politician
said that this this firm is a scam
and this is the law firm in question
took them to court and that the person
that
left that bad trust pilot if you ended
up paying 25 000 pounds good having to
pay 25 000 pounds for saying that the
company was a scam
yeah um i'm not going to say too much
about myself but um
what you're saying yeah i care what i
say but what i will say is um
watch this space because there's a lot
of very interesting things going on
legally but anyway
moving on from um moving on from that do
you think that sometimes
because here's the thing right there's
like there has to be free speech
yeah so people can say what they want to
say from there but
it can't be a case of oh if you're
unhappy with a customer with your
uh experience with a company you can't
talk about it yeah
it's when you're saying something that's
not true yeah that's that's damaging
when it's a problem
or if you want to say i don't like
someone i think that person's a jerk
right if someone said oh he missed a
penalty i think he's a terrible football
player i should have never done that
penalty or i don't like him
that's fine yeah that's their opinion
yeah there's a difference between saying
something that's
hateful or uh defamatory
or harassing somebody yeah the
the than just saying your opinion but i
think i think you can express your
opinion but also you have to think
is it true is it kind is it necessary
and
sometimes yeah but sometimes you just
don't have to say anything even if you
think someone's like a dick
like what's the point in saying it you
know it's your opinion
you're entitled to that but you don't
have to you know be out there there is a
problem
there's a problem as well when you say
if you're gonna say it um if you're
gonna harass somebody say over and over
and over and over and over again
that's that's their harassment so if i
think i don't like
um you know whatever his name is uh
sterling oh i think i don't know
it happens i love sterling but if i like
sterling and i keep posting all the time
yeah yeah right but if i just say it
once it's my opinion
yeah it's not it's just i think i think
there's that you know but there are laws
in place like some people that were
getting upset with me what about the uh
the
where it crep video on made you think
people are going to cry to talk talk
about that so
samuel did a video with crept and then
it got posted onto lots of different
outlets and then
underneath some of the different you
know it was made you think
yeah made you think might you think all
right you think it's a big instagram
page they
they shared the video okay they shared
it but then in the comments
there's people saying oh samuel or
saying that you're racist
because you asked you asked correct
where he got his money from to purchase
the house
like come on what
bro what are you talking about man for
the record
well i said to crap i can't even deal no
what i said to him i was asking about
the house about the figures and
everything like that just like i always
do whenever
i take one of my students anyone yeah
whenever i take a student around one of
their properties and they're showing me
i'll ask them you know what the prize
what's
this what's that and then i'll say how
did you buy it he said oh i bought it
for 43 grand bought it cash
and then i asked him okay cool and where
did you get the cash from now
dare you ask a black person where they
got their money no but but but
the reason i asked that question was
because it's just
i always asked if someone said oh boy
because because because the viewers
might be thinking oh it's all right for
them
they've got loads of money they
inherited it or they've you know maybe
and it's like no you've this person's
actually got a business or they've got
an
art or their and they've worked for the
money yeah and i even said on the
interview i'm not saying you've got
a you you're you're a rapper you're an
artist and you're and i joked and i was
like and you
you you know you're pretty good yeah i'm
joking
um people go no he's being racist he
went to a white rapper i'm like calm
down right um you know so
so i'm just trying i'm asking where i've
got the money from to boost him up to be
like
you've made this yeah and now you're
making fast pound with your music and
then you're investing into property to
make slow pound and passive income
like yeah i mean i don't like people
looking for problems where there's no
problems i just think it's so
ridiculous yeah i think at the moment
i'm sure crept
well no i'm sure i know crep knows that
yeah
[Music]
they're saying oh this video's full of
microaggressions
oh man like honestly i think people just
look for things
that aren't there and then the
microaggressions in my opinion
is then like sometimes looking just
taking any comment that's not racist
but then it's like it's not quite it's
not out there racist so i can't call it
racist but i'll call it a
microaggression so then
it's deemed as like oh this person's i
don't know
being racist in a subtle way but i just
think come on like really
i'm sure microaggressions can be a thing
if so like if someone's
racist in the heart and they want to say
stuff but they can't because they know
they'll be in trouble so they're just
little things like i'm sure that's a
thing and it's disgusting
but then when people are saying that
about me like saying i'm racist because
i asked crept where we got the money
from when if you watch the video in its
context
clearly i wasn't trying to be racist i
was i was very
i've like mad respect for crept
mad love like i was boosting him up he
loved the video he approved it before it
went out
and then there's like literally hundreds
of people
liking the comment of someone saying how
racist i am
they obviously just don't know you and
don't know your heart so it's just it's
obvious because come on like it's just
yeah or they haven't
or they haven't seen they haven't seen
my context of videos where i ask
everybody that questions yeah so then
they just think but then i think
for someone to just think that anyway to
me it's just stupid that
like why would you be offended that oh
this first this white person asked this
black person where you got his money
from like to me it's just stupid i can't
even understand it so
yeah i can't relate right it's just what
do you think folks
again we want your opinions yeah let us
know in the comments what are we writing
something
micro aggressive and racist too crapped
when i asked him
where he got the money from
obviously i knew the answer was well you
know i knew the answer was music
but anyway was it racist was it not even
yesterday i
put a disclaimer another video i did
with uh jessica oh yeah
when i put it on instagram because
because on tick tock i had so much hate
i only when i posted on instagram i had
to put by the way guys
this is a joke yeah i'm gonna put the
videos
people just don't yeah i get what
happened on the video what did i say
oh my gosh so sammy was just saying oh
and why do i want to be really really
wealthy yeah i'm already a millionaire
i said if i'm already a millionaire why
do i keep on working what's my why
what's my reason
yeah and then and then it kind of shows
jessica our baby girl in the back
and then it seems like he's gonna say oh
because i want to do it for my kids but
then he's like oh excuse me and then he
pushes her out of the way
and then he says because i want a jet so
it's just a joke video
but again people people just take things
really literal so that's part you know
this is a joke anyway a few questions
that we have
from from the fans thanks for watching
guys
thanks for watching and listening if
you're listening this is on spotify as
well and itunes if you want to listen to
it as a podcast
all right amanda what have you learned
about life
from having kids oh i've learned
actually it's very interesting with kids
they forgive so
quickly it's so sweet like literally
something will happen or they'll be
playing luke and ruby will be playing
and then one will hurt the other and
then the other one starts crying and
then i'm like oh
and then i say luke say sorry to ruby
and then it's just like she's crying
and then as soon as he just goes sorry
and gives a cuddle and then she's like
okay
and then they start playing again and i
just think watching them it just reminds
me doesn't it like sometimes
as adults you sometimes can hold a
grudge or not forgive someone
but i mean kids just let things just let
go of things so easily i think it's just
something that we can learn from kids so
i always observe that and i think oh
that's really cool and then i just take
note and think ah
you know i should be like that one
things i've learned from kids is that
kids are in the present
all the time they're not thinking about
the future
um they're not thinking about the past
like holding on to resentment
just in the present and i think that's
one of the reasons why kids are often
happy yeah and our kids are
ridiculous yeah because they're just in
the present they say that um when you
think about the future too much it can
cause anxiety
when you think about the past too much
it can cause depression but when you've
just in the present that's where true
happiness is
so okay cool next spontaneity or
stability
oh i like you want both
i was gonna say i'm a bit a bit of birth
but which one more spontaneous
stability ah stability stability yeah
you bring this one to spontaneous into
my life i feel
yeah i like i like you know stable yeah
steady
what about you i'd say probably
spontaneously
i don't like a boring life yeah that's
the one thing i don't ever want
a boring life which i can assure you our
life is definitely not boring
it's lots of things but it's not boring
um but then stability is good you want
financial stability yeah
but ultimately you can't have complete
stability
anything can happen you can have a car
accident
um you can um have a health issue lose
your job you can your business can go
bad yeah
even if your business is great and
you've got all the stability you can
suddenly go into a lockdown
like if you want to build stability and
you
i just think now man you just gotta
enjoy each day and
be spontaneous have fun all right the
last question is
what are oh we've already covered this
question i was gonna say about your
birthday but
i have to change the question because
we've already talked about it are you
excited for being 29
i am excited i'm interested to see if
you know
what will happen well i wake up and
something will be like ah like an
enlightenment or well you've had you've
had 28 birthdays before
has that ever happened ever oh no just
i'm just wondering you know
wait wait wait you thought you do have
that feeling do you no
anyway guys i hope you have enjoyed
listening to the wisdom
and wonders of amanda isn't she amazing
and i hope you enjoyed this
if you have questions comment below
subscribe like the channel and we will
see you guys
next time
you